essentially the question is bad habits
versus addiction what is the difference
yes think about choice right like with
habit Choice plays a larger role with
addiction part of addiction is the
removal or the denigration of choice in
the matter but do you feel like this is
a compulsion do you feel like your
engagement with it is outside of your
control is it something you covet is it
something that you uh you know tell lies
about that you rationalize or downplay
and then getting honest about what the
costs of of this Behavior are to
yourself and also to other people you
know deep down when the head hits the
pillow
the clarity is there